I think one become the nicest man on
earth I think that might be like that's
actually kind of merely where I think
I'm now interested in going
[Music]
so quick back about 15 why 90% of the
students are immigrants and you're
speaking to a lot of students we kind of
wanted to keep it close within the 16y
community the number one thing that I'm
trying to leave here with is to get a
couple of you to get real [ __ ]
patient because that is the singular
advantage if you actually don't give a
[ __ ] the way I didn't of what people
think about you all through your 20s
like you just don't care like you
literally don't and you just build
something for yourself you have a much
better chance so many people here will
fail in their entrepreneurial you know
journeys because they're worried about
what people think that's just what it is
my man that's just what it is people are
worried about what other people think
how many followers they have how good
the business is doing what they're doing
where they're going what they're wearing
doesn't [ __ ] matter
every single person wanted to be a
rapper
1994 everybody was gonna and I remember
thinking like wow how you gonna be a
rapper if you're not writing how you
gonna be a rapper if you're not in the
studio how you gonna be a rapper if
you're not like hustling and it's funny
like the white boy version of that now
is tech like everybody thinks they're
going to build snapchat and Instagram
and I'm like how you gonna do that
when you're at Coachella basically like
it build if you think about like
building a house everybody's worried
about like decorating the [ __ ] room
and like what lighting are you going to
have what colors your wallpaper and
meanwhile the cement you built the house
on is [ __ ] and it's not going to matter
because the first time it's going to
rain your shits going to fall right and
so that's what everybody just jump in
everybody's so impatient you want to
listen I get it I look around this room
and I sociate you know I don't look
exactly like everybody but I can't come
from that same kind of place with a lot
of people right when you have that chip
on your shoulder the hardest thing to do
is patience I'm
so forth and shara shara oh my god
understood I think juggle any face ha
turns off you could dwell on that
struggle which is very real or you could
change your perspective and be like ok
it's the odds of becoming a human being
on 400 trillion to one my favorite story
of my life is playing checkers with the
founder of uber Travis we're not this
fancy [ __ ] conference in Hawaii but
we're playing checkers right just like
2:00 in the morning I will just plain
[ __ ] Shepherds right and I'm a deep
[ __ ] like it's over like you've got like
it's like if you've ever played checkers
I'm finished and some like hot man I
really don't want to lose this match and
so and so I decide to I think about it
for a little bit and cut like over a
couple moves and I decide to make
pretend that I made a move that I'm
upset about hoping that he reacts to it
quickly so I make this move and I go
[ __ ] and like try to make pretend that I
need to go back but like my hand was up
ready so he jumps me which set up a
triple jump for me and I won that's how
I think about your life
[Applause]
semmen that what a whole lives I've seen
them struggling at the back that's where
I learned I mean in the second part is
enough someone so much that you put your
dreams on the shelters to provide a life
with them that you never having yourself
over call automation d4 not you miss
over no fun what is this other vessel
but never set open letters these rabbits
people progression they don't get back
and see this is ridiculous this is this
one muscle knock you out you like this
one just this right here how you doing
I'm good right here my claws my pleasure
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 252 of the askgaryvee
show
I think you've got to make your actions
back up your ambition right like my
process is very simple which is I've
taught the big game I have a lot of
wants and dreams and my schedule today
needs to map my big [ __ ] mouth right
like that's it and so you know one thing
that shocks people when they get close
to run when Tyler first filmed when
Justin first film iris when you get to
film the biggest thing you're going to
know is like wait a minute it's every
second it's actually every second like
it's you know like I think time is the
asset and so the one thing I would tell
you is as you're prospecting as you're
trying to get sales you've also got to
deliver on your work if you've got an
agency like selling just the beginning
selling selling except like you're
something like everybody's so focused on
selling a lot of people starting these
small social media agencies just to get
clients they forget that after you get
the clients you got a [ __ ] deliver
keeping business that keeping business
is what actually builds big businesses
not getting you business so I need to
leave you the question today is who are
you who are you willing to be I love
that I appreciate it thank you you guys
keep watching you keep asking questions
we'll keep answering them so that your
problems with situations in assistance
of super Monday doesn't it so the mud is
it if there's a local conference but
you've amassed an amount of wealth and
investing the crucifix in excess of
saving yourself
Oh show India
yeah I'm still here
I'm still here hello why don't we go
around why don't you tell me who you are
where you're from and just one or two
sentences of what you do and then we'll
go back around and maybe do a little QA
and shoot the [ __ ] a little bit first
and foremost thank you so much for being
a part of this this is something that
has been really exciting for us
something I hear a lot from Baner
employees where it's 700 plus people is
like well it's different and it's not
like it was or this that or we used to
and I'm like yeah I don't know like of
course I'm still me I'm still me at 41
I'm just different than I was at 32 and
at 26 you know it's the intent in the
heart and the passion that has to be the
same but how it manifest looks different
the big thing is you so I would tell you
the number one thing bro is that you and
your brothers have to have a lot of
communication like do you feel line
within oh yeah it's great great so let's
start there you need to have a really
hardcore like crying type conversation
of the blueprint of how you guys don't
let this business break you up and
here's how I would attack it you guys
need to have a conversation around
talent you need to agree which could get
real ugly so stick with me area on who's
more talented right now I promise you
you'll be able to keep everything the
way you want if you and your brother are
aligned everything stems from the top
and then just comes down to how much you
guys care about you care about and
obviously and like but you can't be
crippled everybody here is judging
themselves we're just doing the best we
can like like I get so sad when
somebody's like this place changed I'm
like cuz and they're saying it in a bad
way it hurt breaks my heart but like I
know I'm doing everything I can to not
make it feel worse I can't course it's
changed everything's changed the world
changes everything is always changing
thank you guys
awesome I'll coming for you I'll come
and see you next couple weeks or you'll
come here for words we'll figure it out
but um I'm looking forward to catching
up if I just wasn't a contentious
meeting I'd be willing to be late but I
need turn on awesome thank you be here
thank you for being so pathetic yeah
I'll catch up with you soon okay okay
thank you am I lost in my thoughts I'm
doing the best I can I have to put
myself in their shoes I have a critical
mind a church what someone's been
through while they yet the way they get
to do the things that they do it's okay
Jeff I'm Jung we're gonna happen to this
call tomorrow just because I have to be
on upstairs for Boston Consulting
talking like two minutes I'm just I'm
just I'm just going to hear what Joe's
gonna say right now about what Dan wants
I just texted him we're all gonna get
together but we should be interchanged
don't be your birthday your sense possib
and it's the truth everything in due
time it's not advantage to fix the
forget thing it takes to just multiply
by two but you'll see your bigger
pictures in the woods you cover that you
[Music]
so growing up and growing up in the
liquor business I've always learned that
it's super hard to compete with alcohol
so everybody back there do your thing if
you're not hurting healing people just
not practitioners this room is filled
with people who have a whole lot of
things to say about stuff but have never
she's done it there's a lot of opinions
here of buying snapchat filters in yoga
market there's a lot of opinions here if
you like that and I say it because I do
it in every other thing that I don't
know what the fuss I'm talking about
right I thought opinions of everything
and and but what's been a fascinating is
that people got opinions on what's
actually happening but they're not
practitioners we have a massive
disconnect between headline reading and
practitioner shift in the modern day of
running businesses and marketing and
that is an enormous arbitrage of
opportunity and it's also the preview to
a whole lot of carnage and so I don't
know I think Optimus and I as somebody
who's most comfortable in chaos think
this is going to be the best
like I definitely want Wall Street to
melt I want I'm so tired of all these
peacetime generals these CEOs that have
been navigating the last seven years of
good times I think we need a massive
correction I would prefer it
and in that correction there will be an
enormous opportunity because the biggest
brands in the world overhead and
infrastructure it's based on a world
that doesn't exist anymore
right I think way too many people here
debate and have a romantic point of view
of how they want the world to be I just
react to the way the world is actually
acting like Who am I to judge I was told
as a kid playing video games was a waste
of time I'm watching kids making fifteen
million dollars a year playing sports
[ __ ] changes right and so I think that
I'm I'm not sure but what I will say is
this the only great arbitrage to the
Internet itself that is even out there
is VR but as I was talking to somebody
earlier I believe that consumer VR is
quite far away like we said you know I
react to reality nobody here knows
somebody that's spending three hours a
day on VR everybody here is spending
seven hours a day on their phone thank
you guys fun yes oh well yeah and my
foot can I go Canada [ __ ] I think let me
come man on earth I think that might be
like that's actually kind of weirdly
where I think I'm now interested in
joining again so I live with a criticism
he wasn't given the beginning put it
upon a pedestal a pendant for your
thoughts but I never ever changed my
work at this ridiculous and your this
madness saying I swear to God and I
wrote it off with a pure attention the
truest Testament would know except to
for aesthetic
an imagined effect of the epidemic crew
this is my hottest old in this midnight
just going to shove with team do rock
here you go selfie video
[Music]